phoenix used to be the face of valorant
i got this
he looks absolutely on for this one
pushing for oh no
oh
that's
he was the game's most exciting agent a
key part of any good team comp 58
of the pollsters put this guy top three
height here in their rankings by far
number one was phoenix and yet as the
months wore on he started to fall from
glory we only have one character in the
f-tier right now and it's phoenix
phoenix went from being one of the best
most popular agents in valorant to
literally being completely unpickable in
pro play i can entry
i might lurk i op
i rifle
so having that versatility i'm able to
do with like
jet for example um not really with
phoenix so we had to ask
what happened to phoenix oh
you're dead
hey folks before we get a video i want
to let you know that if you are watching
this as soon as it comes out you can
still tune in to our vctna watch party
liz is going live this weekend and
watching all of the games with you our
fans it's gonna be an awesome time so
please show up okay so phoenix is
basically the face of valorant he was
one of the game's original agents one of
three duelists available in the beta and
by far the most exciting one at the time
ranked number one uh 58
of the pollsters put this guy top three
height here in their rankings by far
number one it was phoenix aggressive
players like strived on that agent
because they could just speak whatever
they want and at the time that was like
the best flash you can have like it's
just phoenix flash in valoran's early
days as teams were still figuring out
how to build the best comp phoenix
seemed like a no-brainer pick after all
he was an entry character that had a
little bit of everything oh they're
going straight from the dark cover
that's going to connect the screen
beautiful stuff here link though takes
down that said amazing stuff here so far
from liquid deflecting this attack
scream is tapping the heads that's what
he does that's who he is
my hands to eliminate some positions
actually oh actually
zom's
just stuck in that position of very low
on hp and with that said now oh my god
there's a chance here forz against
shazam now he knows exactly where he is
suzanne with the peaks can he find the
shot here there goes the hot hands oh he
falls forward for phoenix i think the
main reason why a lot of people were
playing at the start because like most
people came from cs go and he's like
that agent that they had you know had
the same kit as csgo so i think that's
the reason why a lot of people are
playing at the start i still think
everything will change over time and and
i think those rankings will in a month
from now already look drastically
different
but i do think venus phoenix is up there
just because of his kit
phoenix's curveball a flashbang with a
unique curving trajectory seemed like a
great way to enter a sight his blaze
wall could cut a sight in half and
enemies passing through it took damage
and briefly had their vision limited
while phoenix was healed by it his
molotov hot hands had obvious use for
clearing close angles plus like his wall
phoenix could use it to heal himself a
massive benefit for an entry character
and for all the entry fraggers who were
still learning their role there was his
ultimate run it back which basically
brought phoenix back from the dead if he
screwed up or just wanted to gather
intel phoenix cloned himself and the
player got to run around with the copy
when the copy died or time expired
phoenix returned to the place where he
popped his all pretty much unscathed
phoenix was seemingly built to be a team
player while the other duelists in the
game were a lot more selfish
reyes reyna and jet all had their
strengths but this early period in
valoran's history was phoenix's golden
age especially in north america where
some of the region's best saw phoenix's
potential and went deep on the agent
one enemy remaining baby
let's just relax
oh that's a big fight on the surprise
drone has hardly anything left in his
kit oh
what he picks up two brags
he's looking for a third he might get
himself a fourth here he finds him
around the corner and he's gonna get the
ace
but as the game's competitive scene grew
and developed the meta shifted towards
other agents and phoenix's time at the
top was about to come to an end
i think the moment i realized phoenix
was not it is because i used to watch
noted a lot and he used to make phoenix
actually i used to watch all his videos
and like suddenly he stopped playing
phoenix and like yup
there were a few reasons why phoenix
started to fall out of favor players
began figuring out how to win with other
duelists how to pop off with the op on
jet for example and those agents now
played a much bigger role in effective
team comps but even though phoenix
didn't lose any of his utility even if
it didn't get slightly more expensive
over time his pick rate was still
plummeting so what changed they started
dropping new agents and stuff and he was
kind of forgotten he only was getting
nerfed nerf after nerf like you know his
flashes were getting more expensive and
they never buff him the problem was that
phoenix was the character who was
closest to counter-strike and while cs
would occasionally add the odd gun or
two to the game in its early days unlike
valorant it didn't have some wacky new
utility for players to discover every
patch so what started out as an agent
that most people considered a
fundamental part of any good comp the
self-sufficient entry fragger quickly
turned into the game's worst duelist by
comparison and that didn't improve as
more agents were added either this kit
doesn't help steal as much even though
it can but like yeah you can interview
with him with a team like you can put
your wall in and then flash around it
but obviously there's so much abilities
right now everything's so oversaturated
like you really need the better ability
you can't really always rely on your
guns and that's what phoenix does
back during the 2020 ignition series
phoenix was a popular peck seeing
hundreds of rounds in the hands of
aspiring superstars
one of the winning ways and of course
keeping wardell onto the jet now sabros
and hayes get into three openers towards
this mid side and just like that they're
on a five versus two here semo with not
much to work with
and
tsm
feels like brock lee they're just taking
off the ankle weights they're ready to
fight
i don't like i don't even know what's
happening
but by master three in berlin in 2021
phoenix had basically vanished from
competitive play there was one standout
performance from sick that reminded
everyone that the agent existed but it
didn't exactly kick off a new phoenix
meta zapper on the other side sitting
towards the connector on the a side but
it's sick takes himself forward the
sprays a bit
a little bit fruity a little while but
it's just fine in the end and again
there is still no hope there is still no
way in finally at valorent champions
2021 the biggest tournament of the year
phoenix just didn't get picked at all
for fans phoenix was once an exciting
introduction to a new game but that game
moved on to other agents and his
disappearance from pro play had other
implications as well valerie is its own
game of course but it clearly takes cues
from cs if phoenix's kit was supposed to
be foundational to the game then what
did his disappearing act have to say
about valerian's core design and its
competitive future phoenix was meant to
be one of the faces of the game he was
literally in the launch trailer but
despite riot continuing to slap his face
on all of valor's marketing materials
all of the early phoenix hype evaporated
jet replaced him as valerian's most
exciting agent and it's easy to see why
phoenix's well-rounded entry kit and
pretty much everything else he brings to
the table is totally outclassed by tons
of other agents for example phoenix's
molotov wasn't really designed to be
useful for long lineups which made it
more of a personal tool than a team
asset phoenix had a wall shore but
unlike the walls viper or sage had for
example his was just there to help him
get bodies onto site initially or play
some mind games once he got there hold
on a while and get the gun hold on hold
on
okay
smoking something do something yeah
i'm not trying to do this
and that brings us to what is arguably
the most distinctive part of phoenix's
kit curveball and the one glaring flaw
that it has the unique trajectory of the
flash gave an enemy who was actively
holding the angle plenty of information
about how you'd peak the corner
generally speaking it's not so good for
flashing yourself in which is the major
mistake that a lot of us had when we
first were learning valerian and again
there are now plenty of other agents
that can flash further into a site in a
far safer and less obvious way when
valerian first came out phoenix's flash
was unique but over the course of the
game's life we've gotten the flash that
hunts you down the cs go flashbang the
reptilian flash the flashbang that looks
like a person i mean she's got good aim
but not on the real one
and the list goes on now not all of
these are precisely a flash and they
aren't all equal in every possible
scenario but they all essentially do the
same thing they limit a player's vision
and they do it better than phoenix can
so phoenix's tool kit might look like
the complete package but once you start
comparing his individual abilities to
other options on other agents including
some that were very recently released
his kit just starts looking like garbage
we only have one character in the f-tier
right now and it's phoenix it's official
riot has left the british boy wonder to
rot in the meta it's time to get rework
phoenix trending on social media because
that is the only way he will ever return
to the meta in the current state of the
game now the one truly unique part of
phoenix's kit is his alt run it back
it's supposed to give phoenix the
ability to come back from the dead by
respawning the agent but returning to
your original position means that you're
vulnerable especially if you're
outnumbered you could easily be killed
on a respawn if enemies are around you
and while you could have your team cover
you that makes the alt more of a
liability than an asset showing just
gonna start
that was such a bad spot to do my own
oh my god that's the worst all spot
today it's clear that phoenix has been
outclassed other duelists have taken
center stage and there are even agents
in other roles who do some of his kit
better than he does phoenix has just
fallen behind and pro players definitely
took notice okay so phoenix d here i
mean he needs a belt he needs a mega
buff there's no reason to pick phoenix
considering you know jet
rays exists he definitely needs a rework
i only want to say buffs he just needs a
viewer over the past six months
phoenix's competitive pick rate has
fallen to a level similar to yoru a
duelist that has a kit full of gimmicks
instead of sight entry staples and with
jet as the first choice duelist in
nearly every composition many of which
only need the one it's unlikely you'll
see a phoenix in a competitive match any
time
soon ironically phoenix's struggles
earned him a fan base one that is full
of sickos trying to prove that he's not
as bad as we all think he is youtubers
like xtr and rouzu have built their
channels partially on phoenix's
reputation as the underdog you know what
the funny is like whenever i try to
cue and high-rank games with phoenix
they always be like yo bro you trolling
i'm going to dodge this game i'm like
bro bro listen i'm the best phoenix man
in the game trust me they're like of
course you're the best phoenix man
nobody else played that rousey's
dedication to his low tier pick has
shown us that even if the pros aren't
picking phoenix there are ways to make
him work in ranked games i feel like if
you're a solo
player like a ranked demon and
you're trying to like you know just
chill and play the game and you want to
be like you're on you like you just play
for yourself i think it can work very
well 50 on reyna 50 on skype
and these fanatical phoenix faithfuls
aren't just doing the same things over
and over again for nostalgia's sake
they've actually innovated on the agent
and came up with new ways to use his kit
effectively including ground flashes
wall flashes and the notorious reverse
flash that let you keep the ability
hidden for longer and peak right as the
flash goes off
for me the reason the phoenix worked
very well for me more than others
because like i actually tried to clip
i'm not really interested in winning as
much as i'm pursuing getting that cool
kill you know i think that helps me to
see him this way so i'm obviously kind
of biased about him there's even a
subreddit where phoenix mains can share
their gripes about the difficulties they
experience in rank but also where they
can share ideas about what could be
changed about the agent to make things
better and they've got plenty of
opinions on how to fix him one idea is
to let phoenix cancel run it back to
return immediately to a starting
position though there are definitely
other ideas as well i think his whole
kit needs to be buffed because right now
he's actually like he has the worst
abilities in the game like everything's
useless truthfully there is no quick fix
to the phoenix problem riot has said
that they are looking into him and even
they admit that they're not quite sure
what they want to do with him yet and
there's lots of directions they could
take him in but what everyone agrees on
is that he is in desperate need of help
they did not touch this agent since a
very long time like all the other agents
getting buffed and stuff he's literally
untouched like bro phoenix is literally
the face of the game because like look
at all the cinematics you obviously
think about that guy like you're gonna
do something about it because like he's
the least picked like what else do you
need to see to puff the guy you know
phoenix might have once been a baseline
a touchstone something that could have
been used as a frame of reference in a
tactical shooter that was trying to
change the rules set by his predecessor
but as a duelist phoenix clearly hasn't
kept up the pace set by new agents so
maybe when phoenix gets buffed because i
know he will get buffed because he
really doesn't have much of a place in
the meta if i pick him people think i'm
trolling kind of makes me sad sure you
can still pub stomp with him in a
disorganized ranked game and he does
have a few dedicated mains who are
desperately trying to make him work but
phoenix isn't really contributing
anything that you can't get in a better
form somewhere else phoenix is still a
valor and og he helped create the game
we all know and love today but if riot
truly wants him to rise again well
they really have their work cut out for
them fellow phoenix mains i'm gonna have
to tell you guys all have faith keep on
waiting the puffs are coming the phoenix
meta are gonna be revived we're prepared
stay prepared don't abandon my boyfriend
those are birds
unfortunately there is nothing i can do
about the birds like they're not even
outside my window they're just
just ambient birds
the birds love what's the word for
esports judy video competition these are
esports birds these are ebirds you don't
know this but of course i am a disney
princess and
the birds come to me to dress me in the
morning